cette signature devait mettre fin à des
mois d'incertitude le nouvel accord de
libre échange nord américain maintient
la stabilité et la croissance pour
l'économie canadienne
mais plus le temps passe plus l'entrée
en vigueur de l'accord semble compromise
les trois pays doivent toujours le
ratifier chacun de leur côté avant sa
mise en oeuvre aux états unis le sort de
l'accord est entre les mains des
démocrates qui contrôlent maintenant la
chambre des représentants nancy pelosi
la leader des démocrates demandent des
changements à l'administration from plus
de protection pour les travailleurs
mexicains et pour l'environnement ainsi
que des mesures pour réduire le prix des
médicaments sans à des concerts on avec
lesquels le canada a beaucoup de
sympathie
le canada voici demande d'un bon oeil
mais renégocier l'accord serait ouvrir
une boîte de pandore
au canada des voix s'élèvent pour que le
gouvernement ne ratifie pas l'accord
tant que les tarifs américains sur
l'acier et l'aluminium demeure en
vigueur siro ratifie la carrière plus de
levier possible d'autant plus qu'ils
font mal à l'industrie
concrètement ça représente un impact
tarifaire de 60 millions de dollars par
mois juste pour l'industrie primaire
publiquement le gouvernement n'a jamais
voulu promettre qu'il ne ratifiera pas
le nouvel accord tant que les tarifs
douaniers de meuron c'est très difficile
de comprendre comment on peut ratifier
une nouvel accord quand les tarifs sont
toujours en place
vu les délais aux états unis rien ne
presse selon cet expert dans les trois
pays ne l'ont pas ratifiée n'ont pas
adopté les lois nécessaires pour le
mettre vigueur il est caduc
il ne sert à rien on continue
d'appliquer l'aller 9 0 par contre il ne
reste que quelques mois pour adopter la
loi de mise en oeuvre de l'accord avant
la fin de la session parlementaire et la
prochaine élection fédérale
mais même si les conservateurs devaient
prendre le pouvoir
ça ne voudrait pas dire la mort de
l'accord au canada les négociations sont
pas dans le groupe par contre c'est
mieux que rien donc si le gouvernement
américain décide d'enlever les tarifs
sur l'aluminium l'acier on se rend mieux
à ce moment-là de débat du projet est de
prendre le monsieur le président
américain donald trump menace toujours
de déchirer l'actuel accord de
libre-échange l'alena une stratégie pour
faire plier les démocrates mais qui
laisse planer au canada le spectre de
l'incertitude
il suffit de bien sans foyer radio
canada